القتال لا يتوقف في السودان لكن خدمه
المياه والكهرباء توقفت ازمه انسانيه
خانقه تلح في سماء البلاد اجزاء واسعه
بالاحياء السكنيه في العاصمه تعاني شحا
شديدا في مياه الشرب بعد نقص الامداد
المائي من المحطات المزوده محطات المياه
الرئيسيه بالعاصمه تعرضت لاضرار بالغه
جراء الاشتباكات الازمه تفاقمت اكثر مع
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده استهلاك
المياه في شهر رمضان اما انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي فبات عاديا وحكايه مالوفه
وانعاد برزت مشكله توقف شراء الخدمه من
التطبيقات البنكيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات